god whoever invented free jelly baby
praise god
they knew i was going to come into the
world and i would be looking for
something like that
sometimes i'll lay in bed at night and
just think about all the packets of free
jelly that are out there
behind every counter at every you know
fast food joint just right under the
just right under the ledge
just a bucket of damn free jellies baby
and dual jellies
strawberry and grape strawberry and red
baby
and i call it yelly sometimes sometimes
i just can't even sleep just thinking
about all the individual packets
and you know first jelly was all
together and then they [ __ ] separated
it man
and i don't know who came in the germans
or a bunch of business people came in
and just
hey hey hey no no no
no no no and then they put it all in a
little packet little orphan
little orphan t's tablespoons of jelly
bruh but damn there's something
beautiful man if you close your eyes and
think about all the jelly that's out
there
god that's that's remarkable
you